the left-wing media today deemed out
they seemed downright giddy at the
prospect of Congress moving forward on
impeachment and in fact it's almost like
they were all reading from the same
script
it's basically Congress it's now up to
you it's your call
he was virtually announcing Congress do
your job
the train whistles blowing and Pelosi
has got to make a decision he's saying
to Congress and in the House Democrats
are in Congress I can't do your job for
you
the ball is in their court the ball is
essentially in their court it's up to
you folks in the House of
Representatives to deal with this ya
ball is in your court my god do they all
the same scriptwriter joining me
exclusively Brad parts Gayle Trump's
2020 campaign manager Brad are you
worried after today yeah no I'm not
worried look the person who had a bad
day today was Nancy Pelosi
the people had bad days here the people
running for president for the Democrats
I mean they expected I think they were
salivating thinking something's going to
come and what they get today another day
no case against obstruction no collusion
we couldn't charge I mean everybody
today is running with he couldn't charge
because of this old DOJ policy Bart came
out and said well those conversation we
had didn't even like that was his
justification they have a bit of a
conflict and they said they don't have a
conflict I think that's a wash every no
one can follow that but I do think it
was muddying the waters once again on
this issue of did he obstruct justice in
a way that Congress could use to impeach
him look I I still think this goes back
to Democratic talking points and what
they want and this is what the truth is
their impeachment to their base is like
the wall is to our base this is their
fundraising thing and the truth is this
is a made-up false problem in crisis but
our wall is a real crisis and you know
you know that because what's happening
with traffic and all these things but
this this is about them raising money
what do they do they're gonna raise
money on free stuff and what are they
gonna do they want issues I think one of
the things that's a real problem for
them is this economy I mean there's
gonna be gyrations with a trade so for
China but in general this is a booming
economy what are they gonna do so they
have to they have to dangle that little
prospect of impeachment out it's really
I mean as a Democrat if I were a
Democrat you got to kind of have people
thinking you might impeach you might not
so Pelosi today
and I think we have it Pelosi today
talked about her being disappointed with
the DOJ let's watch I am gravely
disappointed in the Justice Department
for their attitude their
misrepresentation of the mother report
to begin with they're hiding behind
something that you could never find in
the Constitution that the president is
above the wall and their
misrepresentations even under oath by
the Attorney General to the Congress of
the United States look I've never seen
your beat in this drone because they
think this is gonna raise the money but
the problem is this actually empowers
our campaign it's going to it doesn't
help them it actually strengthens our
campaign coming forth because this is
something that that most Americans when
you look at don't actually agree with I
mean like sometimes this thing pulls
less than 5% people don't believe this
they think they're just trying to beat
them in some way because they have no
other way to beat him on policy and
Americans see through this and pull
after poll shows that and it strengthens
the campaign it has every single poll
since they started doing this Justin
Amash is now the the one Republican
knows now that he's the courageous one I
want you to watch this exchange I think
it's really important that we do our job
as a Congress that we not allow
misconduct to go undeterred that we not
just say someone can violate the public
trust and that there are no consequences
to it look this guy comes out says he's
a libertarian but what did you believe
in he believes in fake dossiers he
believes his spine he believes in you
know false fights of things I mean like
he's not libertarians I'm worried about
him running against the prow at all no I
don't think so I'm looking I think
libertarians go see through him too I
think you'll see them coming out against
him because he doesn't believe in
Liberty brett-brett a nice muscle shirt
on yeah
all right thank you so much